let's get the news now dr. Liam Fox the
former defense secretary and
conservative candidate who joins us now
from Bristol thank you very much for
being with us labour have said today
that they will ensure there is a
nuclear-armed submarine at sea at all
times and that their expert advice is
that that requires four submarines so
where is the difference with
conservative policy well the difficulty
of course is with the political
arithmetic it's very clear that if
Labour lose a lot of the Scottish seats
which does look likely then the SNP are
likely to be a potential coalition
partner for them they have said not only
do they want nuclear weapons out of
Scotland they want the entire United
Kingdom to be without nuclear weapons
that poses a risk for a future potential
continuation of our nuclear deterrent
which is extremely important at a time
when you're seeing a resurgent and
aggressive and expansionist Russia it
doesn't though does it because it knows
circumstances we can assume that a
conservative opposition would vote with
a Labour government to maintain the
nuclear deterrent well quite how strong
is libres commitment and I hope that we
do have a continuous nuclear deterrent
policy in this country is very important
for our national security the New
Statesman serving Labour candidate said
75% of them are against trigons in fact
55 of them have come out and said they
wouldn't sound you'll of the deterrent
program except that there are people in
labor who are opposed to this policy but
all I'm saying on past precedent you
personally in those circumstances if you
were in opposition and the vast majority
of your conservative colleagues would
vote with a Labour government to renew
the nuclear deterrent wouldn't you but I
think the safest way of course is to
have a concept of government that
believes in the the concept of nuclear
deterrence and I was interested that you
said but labor today we're now saying
that they would have four submarines
committed to the program because it sold
out today that I wonder if those books
were saying they would happen yes we've
had a different number we've had three
today we've had four we've had around
four we need to have a commitment to it
because
you can't actually have continuous
at-sea deterrence with three submarines
on current technology it does actually
make a difference it may sound a very
small matter but it's not and would you
accept that this is pretty low politics
talking not about what labour is
promising but what their alleged
potential coalition partners the SNP is
saying and then rounding it off with a
personal attack on that Miliband well I
find you know this idea that no
politicians ever get into our political
personal comments that when I've heard
all the comments about George Osborne
and David Cameron from the Labour Party
for the last several years leaving that
aside I think that what you have here is
a situation where the electoral
arithmetic says that Labour couldn't
govern alone they would require the SNP
to back them up the SNP don't want a
nuclear deterrent it's a fairly simple
commitment the conservative parties made
very clear that we will commit to four
submarines we will pay for the upgrade
and these numbers being banded about Oh
nonsense we estimate us about 25 billion
over 25 years which doesn't sound like a
lot of money for protection from nuclear
blackmail compared to nine billion for
the Olympics for three weeks so we can
really need to try to get the priorities
right it's a very dangerous world other
countries out there are trying to get
nuclear weapons we're potentially prone
to nuclear blackmail the only way we can
prevent that is have a continuous at-sea
deterrent it's the only way to make it
work the Liberals idea of course is
quite bonkers and that you would only
have a partial deterrent and wheeler
tight when international tension got
worse that seems to me to be the
craziest policy of all but what we must
have is a continuing defense nuclear
posture for the United Kingdom
mentioning other liberal democrats your
coalition partners isn't it true that
one of the failures of this government
from a conservative perspective has been
that you would like to have made this
commitment to the nuclear submarines
already but you had to postpone that to
gratify your liberal Democrat partners
it's one of the realities of coalition
politics that you can always get exactly
what you want and we certainly went a
long way to ensuring that the program
was ready should we pray we'll be able
to press the button immediately after
the election I manifest was going to
make very clear our commitment to that
and the public will have to decide
in a very dangerous world who they
actually think is going to be more
responsible with their national security
I'm very glad that we've got into this
debate today because I was beginning to
wonder whether international affairs a
national security would form part of
this election and I think it's getting
the voters are very clear choice ever
the part that making is that you as
conservatives might end up reforming the
coalition with the Liberal Democrats and
you might not be able to deliver on what
you're saying today about the nuclear
deterrent because you'd have to buy them
off well the Liberals of course went
along with the investment in the
replacement for the Trident submarines
and that was a reasonable thing for us
to to do we've spent a great deal of
money on this program already where we
not to continue it would mean a lot of
job losses in the United Kingdom as well
as the loss of our international
prestige and I think having looked at
all the alternatives that when if F
reality came around I'm sure they're at
least some of the Liberal Democrats
would see would see the light on this
issue would you like to repeat what your
successors Defense Secretary Michael
Fallon has said today do you think that
Ed Miliband is a backstabber I think the
question that he put was very legitimate
would never be willing to give up
something that a lot of their MPs don't
like anyway in order to get that fees to
number 10 now whatever whatever the
answer to that question is it's
certainly a risk for the British people
than it's something that voters will
want to have in mind when they go to the
ballot box on the 7th of May what so
you're saying you think here's a
backstabber I think it's a question that
is perfectly legitimate is the Labour
Party and the Labour leader would they
be willing to trade away in a deal with
the SNP our nuclear deterrent simply to
get the keys to number 10 I wouldn't
like to have to gamble on that answer
okay got Fox thank you